how proud of louis are you with tom gunn
i mean it's brilliant and he is so great
in it yeah he's incredible i couldn't be
more excited for him you are performing
tonight we heard you do a little sound
check how you feeling heading into your
performance
i feel good you know um
i'm excited to share my music with
whoever's here and hopefully everybody
has a good time
i hear you have something like 80
unreleased songs
um
it's probably close to that i have a lot
of unreleased music
when when will that change from
unreleased to released
um i'm trying to figure it out you know
um
so much of my music
i think maybe i've doesn't feel as
important to me anymore and i'm trying
to i'm probably just going to keep
writing more and trying to figure figure
out exactly like
really i'm trying to write an album
right now and i've i've only released
like singles and eps before so i'm
working on something more cohesive that
feels um
representative of where i am now um so i
don't know i don't really know if i'm
gonna ever release the stuff now
it's all in flux maybe in the future but
yeah i'll definitely be releasing some
something whether it's songs that
already exist or new stuff soon
representative of who you are now how
would you describe that what is that
what is inspiring you right now
um
well i think something that's different
about
what i'm working on now versus what i've
put out in the past is
i
i feel a lot happier and i think a lot
of the music that i've released in the
past um
i've been
almost like used music as therapy in a
way and definitely like written about
like all the whatever sort of like
painful experiences i was going through
which um definitely has its place too
but um i want to work on how to
write it's a challenge for me to try to
write music that feels joyful but is
also
not cheesy
so
um so that's something that's uh that
i'm in in the process of figuring out
right now would some of that happiness
have to do with that sweet man of yours
definitely yeah he'll be here soon with
my dad so my brother just had a baby
today a lot to be happy about
so much to celebrate in your sister's
getting married yeah exactly
how is wedding planning going how
helpful are you i would imagine you're
the maid of honor
i'm sure it will be yeah
um she's been working for the past
couple months so uh in paris i haven't
been able to see her as much as normal
but um
yeah i'm super i'm excited to do all the
planning with her and everything and
take lead on the bachelorette party
right yeah for sure
what would you what would you do like
hypothetically speaking how would you
approach a bachelorette party for your
sister you know her the best yeah i mean
she's not a big party girl i think she's
gonna want something that's like
spa related you know
like she's big into like
yoga or she recently got into yoga and
massages i don't know so i'm sure she
probably just wants to like hang up
their girls and do something nice for
herself who needs vegas when we can just
have a spa day
now that sweet man of yours you two
are one of my favorite young couples in
hollywood now did you guys meet through
your parents because they of course know
each other we met
through uh two of my best friends they
set us up and then actually like we
realized when we had started dating like
our parents had done a movie together
we watched it together one night
[Laughter]
how what were the reactions when you
watched it together i mean
it's all it was like fun to watch them
but it's also like kind of feels
embarrassing and like you know
did you guys bond at all about growing
up with
hollywood parents because that's
something not a lot of people do share
but i guess in hollywood maybe a lot of
people do share that i mean i didn't i
grew up in north carolina so i didn't
really know a lot of people that had
similar experiences to me um until i
moved out here um so yeah i mean i think
it's definitely like a common
understanding
you know what's so funny that i realized
today is you are friends with kaya
gerber and you both have boyfriends
right now who are battling for that top
spot at the box office have you thought
about that
i hadn't thought about it yeah top gun
verse elvis yeah
how proud of louis are you with top gun
i mean it's brilliant and he is so great
in it yeah he's incredible the movie's
so great i'm yeah i couldn't be more
excited for him with you and the music
and him with the acting i love it you
guys are a power couple thank you
[Music]
you